The unstoppable force redefining this landscape, is tonight on a collision course...
...with a geothermal power plant, already destroying a warehouse.
Explosive fissures, shooting fountains of lava and fireballs into the sky...
...are now creeping closer to where toxic gases are stored,...
...workers scrambling to shut down three underground wells.
A lot of people are really freaking out.
After another explosion at Kilauea's crater,...
...ash and volcanic smog are drifting.
Laze, when magma cascades into the water, creates a toxic haze...
...that can drift 15 miles.
Meanwhile, the only man injured by a lava bomb while sitting on his porch,...
...is sharing his story for the first time.
It threw me against the wall.
It was like the worst impact I've ever had in my life.
I mean, there's so much force.
Tonight, Kilauea turning part of this tropical paradise...
...into hell on Earth.